during the same period
hammering like I said was struggling to
make the Opera House work he converts a
front section of the building it was for
commercial use into a small music hall
and then you still ended the Opera House
is a long narrow lobby and then a major
opera house buildings to the back side
of the street the 126th Street side of
the of the street and he starts to lease
it out to other players and he leased it
out to a team called Hertog and Seamon
there about 20 brothers and then they
started out as ticket scalpers an
amazing number I couldn't keep coming up
with her Hertog names as I do my
research but they become the agents for
Williams and Walker they take the show
that Williams of Walker is producing
called into home a which is now
reflecting back on the Dahomey villages
that's that the home is really known now
in terms of this association from the
fair so they capitalize on that women
cook is writing music for this along
with Paul Laurence Dunbar the African
American poet but it's really
interesting in 90 this is 1902 her
talkin semen the only black group they
have is Williams of Walker and it's at
the top of their stationery he's there
listed first before all their other
programs so you realize they're bringing
a certain amount of revenue and wealth
to the music business even in 1900 - and
they're being exposed a much broader way
here's an article clip from the show the
show goes to Europe they have a command
performance before the King of England
Cook's wife Abbey Mitchell cooker or
soprano voice is so outstanding that
it's requested that she's saying
specifically lots of the group they're
looking at Africa culture you can see
the the masks in the back but they're
also looking at the post slave
experience you see how they're dressed
it's not panning to what you might have
thought of mistral shows and performance
they're really looking at this as a
miserable class and so a broader
participant in American culture and
we're gonna listen to a little bit of
what
will marry a cook wrote as a piece it's
called the Emancipation Day natal
triumphant that is there's no shuffling
there's no place to shuffle to this is
at the same time Weber's and fields in
this building is still standing on 125th
Street it's a church today they acquired
this theater building is a West End
theatre webber's and fields were to
Jewish comedians one would play a dutch
character one would play a German
character in the Dutch were the
establishment we think of New Amsterdam
in New York the Dutch was seen as the
old guards this is playing off the
German and the Dutch at the same time
that Williams and Walker are producing
shows and again like I was mentioning
promoting using that tag to actually
infiltrate it and get into the theater
they had made so much money off of in
the home a that they didn't want to do
even more spectacular second show called
Abyssinia but her talking semen refused
to put up the money so they had to sue
the separate from her target see made
heard like I see mrs. older our best act
they can't leave us to go to somebody
else and they said well then give us the
money and when they refused to do that
even the judge said well then they're
free they're free agents and so you can
see the actually staged views on 125th
Street and actually staged production a
run at that theater this is 1900 I think
it's 219 - or 19 for 19 of versus a 1907
so that means blacks are occupying the
theatres on 125th Street
even then way before we think about the
Apollo and some of the other places
there's a varying program along the
street but these prominent X are visible
and Sydenham hospitals that's only a
block away I came across the program
where they were the finale act before
the Schubert's and a fundraiser that
honor one of their brothers for the
building of sidon ham hospital and run
across the street still you can't tell
from 125th Street if you go around to
124th you see the back of what was peps
Harlem which was Pabst brewery one of
the largest music and entertainment
dining and entertainment facilities the
United States set 1,400 people and
Sigmund Romberg was a Viennese composer
you now we know them from the movies
red is nothing to me Jeanette MacDonald
he was a young orchestra leader there
and he would got a lot of song pluggers
trying to promote the music there one of
whom was Irving Berlin with Alexander's
ragtime band and they so teased the
Romberg that he can write a ragtime song
if he killed him he came up with this
song leg of mutton that would you see
the sheet cover but I love look at the
chair how she's seated and look at the
restaurant she's actually showing you
the environment he's actually performing
it becomes a very popular song rag song
for music in dining venues